good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight there are a few things
more infuriating than being lied to by
your own government the government you
pay for the one your ancestors risk
their lives to protect does that happen
to you of course it has it enrages you
but if it happens again and again if it
happens often enough if your government
makes a habit of lying to you then over
time it becomes something else over time
you realize you're not really living in
a democracy you can't be because in a
democracy the government has a moral and
legal obligation to tell you the truth
always period
and that makes sense because in a
democracy you are not a subject or a
mere consumer you're a citizen you are a
shareholder in the system you're an
owner of it the people who run your
government are your employees they're
like your cleaning lady you may
appreciate the work they do good job but
the minute you catch them stealing your
cufflinks you fired them
those are the rules because it's your
house not theirs
but what if the rules were inverted what
if you caught an employee stealing but
instead of seeming ashamed and penitent
he whipped around and attacked you like
you were the criminal
well that is the experience of Watching
White House spokesman John Kirby talk
about the destruction of the Nordstrom
Pipelines
anyone who imagines who thinks for a
moment the bite Administration was in
any way involved with that sabotage
directly or indirectly is not simply
wrong no anyone who imagines that is a
bad person a tool of Vladimir Putin
watch
did the U.S or a proxy for the U.S have
anything to do with the explosion on the
Nordstrom pipeline
the United States had nothing to do with
it that's just Russian propaganda and
disinformation now we know it was an act
of sabotage but there's an investigation
going on right now I don't think we're
going to get into uh into credentialing
that in terms of you know who was
responsible uh we're going to let the
investigators take a look at that but
clearly this was an act of sabotage all
right so you can officially say that the
U.S was not involved in any way in this
attack
that's right that's correct not to
belabor this but for the people who look
at this and say why would Russia attack
its own pipeline that creates leverage
over Europe and perhaps the West what do
you say to them
again I can't speak to specific
accountability for this active sabotage
uh I can just assure you the United
States had nothing to do with it of
course uh that's just Russian propaganda
so notice prepares the question did the
U.S did the bite Administration or any
of its proxies have anything to do with
the sabotage
to which John Kirby says we didn't do it
and then moves right to the point which
is anyone who says we did it is
repeating Russian propaganda that's what
John Kirby said it's disinformation from
quizlings more loyal to Vladimir Putin
to than their own country that's the
kind of thing that only truly bad people
say
okay if the White House says so
obviously we have no choice but to
believe it but you still have to wonder
not everyone does believe that why
where might some Americans have gotten
the notion that the Biden Administration
might have been involved directly
through a proxy in the destruction of
the north stream Pipelines
why would they think that they certainly
didn't watch it on Russia Today RT has
been pulled off the air
they didn't hear it from Putin or any of
his ministers you can barely find
anything from the Russian government on
Google and of course any book
sympathetic to Putin has been banned on
Amazon in fact every piece of
information that reflects the modern
Russian point of view has been censored
in the United States because this is a
free country fighting for democracy you
just can't read what you want or think
what you want
so actually if you think about it if
Americans are deluded about what
happened in the Nordstrom pipeline the
delusion didn't come from Moscow because
there's no way for Moscow to get us
disinformation to the United States
because the US government has blocked it
along with the tech companies so where
did that idea come from why might they
think that
well maybe they learned it from Joe
Biden himself he's the president
here's Biden this winter on American
television pledging to destroy the
Nordstrom pipelines if Russia does
something he doesn't want them to do
watch if Russia invades that means tanks
or troops Crossing the the border of
Ukraine again then there will be we
there will be no longer on Norse team
too we we will bring an end to it
would you but how would you how will you
do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's controls
we will uh I promise you we'll be able
to do it
so that's about as clear as it gets
Biden doesn't say we will shut it down
he will say there will be no Nordstrom
pipeline we will put an end to it and
the report says but wait a second it's
not your pipeline
how will you be able to do that
so here's a chance to reframe the
question to revise his answer to be more
precise but he doesn't he says I promise
you we'll be able to take out Nordstrom
Joe Biden president United States
so there's that clue
and that is
as if that wasn't enough last week last
Friday the Secretary of State in the
bite Administration Mr Tony blinken
bragged about how great the sabotage of
Nordstrom was and we're quoting it's a
tremendous opportunity said Tony blinken
it's a great thing
not a tragedy a victory something we're
in favor of we're excited about it
destroyed a natural gas pipeline
we're for that so that might be another
clue
that the bite Administration may have
had something to do with it oh but no
says the White House despite the fact
that we promised we would do it
and then we quote about how great it was
after it happened we had nothing at all
to do with it who did it well Russia did
it
they blew up their own pipeline making
their own country poorer and weaker in
the middle of a major war because that's
how crazy but also diabolically
effective the Russians are suicidal yet
brilliant
and if you don't buy that story
uncritically if you have any questions
about how exactly that might work you're
a disloyal American shut up
here's Chris Stewart a republican member
of Congressman Utah making the very same
point
John Kirby with the National Security
Council was on earlier in no uncertain
terms said the U.S was not behind and a
proxy of the U.S was not behind the
explosion on the North stream pipeline
from your perspective both of you you
you agree with that
oh absolutely this is the last thing
that we want to raise gas prices further
in Europe it's pretty obvious this is a
Russian sabotage operation and for the
people Congressman Stewart that say why
would Russia do that on its own pipeline
what do you say
well then people who are suggesting the
U.S that is exactly what Vladimir Putin
wants
it's just so great I mean it's perfectly
bipartisan
here you have a republican from Utah
Chris Stewart and a Democrat from
Massachusetts Seth Moulton agreeing
precisely
it's exactly what Vladimir Putin wants
he wants you to blame the by
demonstration for something he did
that's the bipartisan view in Washington
what's interesting is they don't really
know that they have no evidence that
that's true
briefers from the Intel agencies has of
have as of this afternoon told members
of Congress they have no idea who
committed industrial terrorism against
these Pipelines now that itself is a lie
of course the CIA has no idea at all
right they have no idea
but as far as members of Congress Chris
Stewart and Seth Moulton know there's no
evidence either way they have no facts
that that is a fact they have no facts
so again as a factual matter neither of
those guys nor any member of Congress no
matter what committee they sit on has
any idea who did this but if you suggest
the obvious Russia probably didn't do it
because why would they do it it's
against their own interest no matter
what dumb story you're trying to sell us
if you suggest that if you apply common
sense you're evil and then they go
farther and say things that are like
completely implausible Seth Molton we're
quoting the last thing we want is to
raise gas prices in Europe
really Seth Moulton is that true
because isn't the bite Administration
philosophically opposed to low gas
prices aren't they opposed to all fossil
fuels oh right they are how do we know
that is that Russian propaganda no
because we can't read propaganda because
it's been banned in favor of our
propaganda we know that because Joe
Biden himself has said so many times on
television okay so maybe there is a
motive here maybe there's more than one
motive
but don't ask
because warn the media asking obvious
questions is forbidden watch
News host Tucker Carlson irresponsibly
claiming the United States was
responsible for the leak other than
Putin and Tucker Carlson it seems pretty
clear that everyone knows that Putin did
this himself and Tucker Carlson uh this
past week actually once again directly
repeated Russian propaganda suggesting
it was somehow the United States behind
the attack on the uh the Nordstrom
pipeline how real is that movement is it
growing hmm
it's Russian propaganda how dare they
really is it really
probably just thought experiment here a
lot of Americans who don't feel any
Allegiance whatsoever to Russia
don't like Putin why would you if you're
an American
but care a lot about their own country
and the behavior of their own government
so if their own government again the one
they pay for the one they supposedly
control is doing things contrary to
their interests and then lying about it
maybe they think they have a right to
know and ask obvious questions like are
you lying and if you're not lying speak
slowly and tell us how your story that
when you're expecting us to believe
makes sense
it's possible that asking questions is a
patriotic duty of Americans
shut up
that helps Putin you're not allowed to
say it you're not allowed to quote the
president of the United States promising
to eliminate the Nordstrom pipelines
you're not allowed to quote his
secretary of state celebrating that
sabotage you're required to believe that
Putin took out his own infrastructure
you must
how does this fit into Putin's Playbook
of course as you would expect Susan
Russia says oh we had nothing to do with
this we're going to launch an
investigation but come on
I look uh you know the indications are
uh that uh Foul Play was involved and
that it appears that you know Russia is
certainly the likeliest suspect of this
I think this is uh clearly a an act of
sabotage of some sort and and Russia is
certainly the most likely uh suspect I
think this might be just the the first
Salvo of some additional things that uh
might be uh coming to toward Europe what
guten is saying to us with with by
blowing up his pipeline is look I can
blow up a pipeline if if need be I can
blow up the internet cables coming into
your country I can blow up functioning
pipelines I could do all sorts of stuff
oh it's Bill Browder he's an expert on
the subject I believe Bill Browder don't
believe your own Lying Eyes there was a
moment after it was very clear that the
war in Iraq was not helping the United
States in any way and in fact hurting
the core interests of the United States
that the media engaged in a rare
nanosecond of self-reflection how do we
get here what role did we for example
the New York Times play in convincing
the public that Saddam had wmd when he
didn't
and for that one moment you thought wow
maybe they're learning something maybe
they won't do it again
but it turns out the opposite happened
now they're just completely doubling
down on what's very obviously a lie and
attacking anyone
who asked to hear it explained
rationally and it's not just the media
by the way DC think tanks whose purpose
is long endow like what's the point of a
DC Think Tank oh to run interference for
the ruling class to bolster the regime
to the praetorian guard
The Brookings institution filled that
role for many years they just produced
this analysis quote U.S podcasters
spread Kremlin narratives on Northern
Nordstrom sabotage
what's interesting about this analysis
is that nowhere in it does the Augusta
Brookings institution rebut
the evidence that the U.S or a proxy of
the bite administration had something to
do with this there's in fact no evidence
either way
instead they just attack anybody who
asks questions quote the theories pushed
by these podcast hosts align with
Kremlin messaging
oh a line with Kremlin messaging they
used to be called guilt by association
Vladimir Putin likes dogs what you like
dogs what are you a Russian sympathizer
right okay it aligns with Russian
propaganda
so the point is it doesn't matter
whether or not it's true it aligns with
Kremlin messaging therefore you must be
censored
but not everybody got the memo there are
tucked away in the Deep recesses of
American society a few honest liberals
still laugh maybe they've been I don't
know in Saint Barts for the last three
years and didn't realize that you could
no longer exercise free speech in this
country one of them is a professor of
Columbia called Jeffrey Sachs so he went
on Bloomberg the other day and was asked
about the Nordstrom pipelines and he
decided to respond rationally and he
said well actually there's quite a bit
of evidence that the by Administration
Administration was involved but rather
than follow up the anchor realizing that
forbidden topics were being Bros War not
to talk about this just shut down the
segment but not before Jeffrey sack said
this
the destruction of the the nordstring
pipeline which I I would bet was a U.S
action perhaps U.S and and Poland uh
stop there that's a that's a quite a
statement as well why do you feel
absolutely that that was a U.S action
what evidence do you have of that
well first of all there's direct radar
evidence that U.S helicopters military
helicopters that are normally based in
Gdansk were circling over this area we
also had the threats from the United
States earlier in this year that one way
or another we are going to end Nordstrom
you're not allowed to say these things
uh in in the west but the fact of the
matter is all over the world when I talk
to people they think the U.S yeah
and by the way even reporters on our
papers that are involved tell me
privately yeah well of course it doesn't
show up in our our media
the anchors clearly getting instruction
to Chrome stop him stop him what what
evidence do you have well there's a
radar evidence what
[Laughter]
shut up
just cut him off never invite him back
stop
the only explanation allowed of course
is the one the government wants you to
believe Vladimir Putin is so evil he's
destroying his own Pipelines
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight